hey youtubers is Charlie so there's a
lot of TV news happening this week the
big networks are having their up fronts
where they present all their new shows
for the next season to advertisers the
bad news is is that Marvel had an agents
of shield spin-off that they decided not
to pick up ABC decided not to pick it up
so I wanted to do my top 5 alternatives
for shows that I think they should
develop there's some interesting
challenges that ABC has that some of the
other networks don't have ABC's growth
as a network has been fueled by a strong
female demographic but they want to tap
into that males age 18 to 34 demographic
so they want to develop shows that that
group will like but will not alienate
the audience that they already have you
always hear a lot of talk about men and
women wanting different things
I think that's complete I think
as long as any story has you know great
comedy sex violence action drama
everyone will enjoy it so this would be
a mixture of female and male lead shows
just starting with number 5 miss Marvel
this one's a little harder to do so
that's why I put her lower on the list
she's a great character and I'm talking
about the Kamala Khan Miss Marvel if you
haven't been reading her comic book
check it out is a lot of fun forget
about her race her gender her religious
beliefs she's just a really interesting
character they're slowly starting to
build out her universe in the comics one
of the biggest reasons I think she's a
really good option is because she's an
inhuman that's where she gets her powers
from Marvel is doubling down on Inhumans
they're gonna be a really big deal on TV
and in the movies
it only makes sense that at a certain
point they would try to do more powers
based show agents of shield right now is
a little bit more superhero CSI with the
procedural elements tuned down a little
bit I don't think that we need another
procedural show the problem that you run
into though with characters like Miss
Marvel is as you know what is their
journey what's their hero arc they get
powers they figure them out what do they
do each week the human drama aspect of
the character is way easier to do she's
a teenage girl so she faces typical
teenage problems but she's also a Muslim
so there's a lot of awkward comedy built
in the fact that she's an American
teenager trying to deal with traditional
Muslim values as well as all the normal
gender politics and school drama that
you would see in a teenage series I
think one of the downsides in selling a
Miss Marvel TV show to like a really
broad audience is that
would have to tune the sex elements down
a little bit that's not really part of
the Miss Marvel character she's not
about sex I mean she's a teenager so
she's just trying to figure stuff out
agents of shield kind of had that
problem there just there wasn't a lot of
sex on the show they slowly changed that
in season two like you have the bobbi
and Hunter character may had that weird
relationship with Ward you just you
can't have a prime-time network TV show
where nobody has any sex teenagers have
sex all the time it'd be disingenuous if
you had a teenage series and nobody was
having any sex on to number four another
really strong female character Spider
Woman this is another one of those
tricky issues spider-man was just
brought back into the Marvel Universe
Marvel has always had the rights to
Spider Woman that's a completely
separate character that's never been a
problem for them but because of their
relationship with Sony they would
probably have to market in a really
interesting way just to try to avoid
stepping on toes Spider Woman is just
one of those really interesting
characters in the comics that they
haven't done a lot with in film or TV
she has appeared in animated form but
we're talking about primetime TV
if CBS can find a way to do superpowers
with Supergirl in a relatively
affordable way then Marvel can totally
find a way to do Spider Woman powers she
also works really well with the agents
of shield angle she's been a member of
shield in the past realistically I think
there will be spider-verse people in the
live-action TV series at some point but
I think it might not come till well
after we see MCU spider-man in his full
glory in film spider-man just in in
terms of pop culture just holds up all
the other spider-verse characters you
have spider-gwen in the comics that's
really interesting but I feel like if
they're gonna do a spider character on
screen they would go a Spider Woman
first if they're not gonna do spider-man
spider go engine starts you know
splintering the mythos and if you
haven't been reading the comics or
keeping up it's really hard to follow
and the downside to network TV is that
they have to be easy enough to follow
for people that have never picked up a
comic book in their life so upside
really strong character with a lot of
potential for integration with the other
Marvel TV series downside they're
probably gonna wait till after the new
spider-man franchise launches to even
think about doing a spider character on
TV fingers crossed for daredevil Netflix
crossover though on to number three
Avengers Academy this is really just
like doing on x-men live-action TV
series just you know replacing it with
Avengers character
it's biggest strength is also its
biggest weakness though Avengers brand
recognition people will tune in
expecting to see Avengers and when Chris
Hemsworth or Captain America doesn't
show up every week
people are gonna be pissed I kind of
explained the deal with the the TV
actors contracts and the film actors
contracts in one of my videos last week
but but basically film actors do not go
on TV not because they don't want to but
because they don't get paid enough as
much as that sucks it's just one of the
realities of film and TV Cobie Smulders
is someone who's an exception to that
because she's really more of a TV
actress that's breaking into film Nick
Fury - but Sam Jackson he'll appear in
anything so he doesn't count it just
feels like it would be too much fun to
see them you know mining characters with
film potential most TV series are
designed to stand on their own like DC
keeps their film and TV universes
separate like that the TV actors
probably never gonna appear in the films
Marvel is all about integration so it
you know at a certain point you think
that they would try to do the Disney
thing where they they mined talent in
the TV universe and then slowly
integrate them into the films TV is just
a really easy way to mined talent
because you can only make a certain
number of films a year but there's way
more room and TV on to number two
another ensemble cast option Marvel
Runaways this is leaning more towards
what's going on to the show right now
you have a bunch of new inhuman
characters some of them good some of
them not so good the show like Runaways
could be like an Inhumans Breaking Bad
situation with younger characters so you
combine all the things that are fun
about the Inhumans the superpowers then
getting into awkward situations based on
their powers and you get the human drama
of shield just like the interpersonal
relationships them trying to figure out
where they belong you know them being
stuck between shield in between the
Inhumans that's why when they announced
the agents of shield spin-off was gonna
be about Mockingbird hunter I was a
little bummed I felt they were gonna
roll harder on the Inhumans maybe that's
one of the reasons why they passed on it
they just didn't want another agents of
shield clone another really good thing
about Runaways is Joss Whedon had a
really awesome run on it and he is great
with young characters on TV he had a big
hand in developing agent to shield his
name is on it but really it's his
brother and his wife that run that show
Joss Whedon isn't really involved with
agents of shield anymore dollars to
donuts though Joss Whedon's gonna spend
most of his time developing indie films
on his own even though everyone wants
him to do Star Wars or
new x-men film and finally my number one
choice for a new Marvel ABC primetime
show Captain America Winter Soldier this
would be a show based on Bucky's
character starring Sebastian Stan like a
limited run he's an actor that's done
both film and TV and he's not one of
those Robert Downey junior level film
actors that's like so busy with film
that he is an overpriced and he has the
room in his schedule to do a limited run
a good analog for him is Dominic Cooper
he was able to do a whole bunch of indie
films last year and do agent Carter and
he's now gonna be starring in the
preacher TV series so if Dominic Cooper
can do his own limited TV series
Sebastian Stan could probably do one too
there's a lot of people that think that
he might get up jump to Captain America
status like he might take the mantle
during Captain America Civil War so that
might put the damper on any kind of
Winter Soldier TV action Marvel is also
really protective of its film properties
that are really strong franchises like
if it feels like a film franchise makes
enough money there's no reason to make a
TV series especially if they have a lot
of other TV series on air already
it's just that Winter Soldier fits the
profile of the type of show that
everyone would get excited about and
wouldn't be overly expensive just
because he doesn't have like a lot of
energy based superpowers he's not like
Superman he doesn't fly around all the
time
mechanical arms super-strength very easy
to do even if he takes the mantle from
Steve Rogers there's no way they're
gonna have time to do a film just for
him where they explore his backstory
even in the movie Captain America Winter
Soldier
they didn't go too crazy into his
backstory he has this whole history
since World War two of being an assassin
then freezing him on thawing him having
him assassinate people it's just that it
would work really well with the arrow
model where you flash back into the past
where he is you see him on his missions
assassinating people and then you see
him in present-day with the character
moving forward you also don't have to
use a lot of the film Avengers
characters because it's not like they
hang out every day so here's my big
question for you guys what TV series do
you want to see ABC and Marvel do next
do you think they have a realistic shot
of doing meaning it doesn't start film
actor that's too busy to do a limited
run TV series and it doesn't require
constant expensive CG the interesting
thing about that though is that agent
Carter actually one of the reasons why
they only did eight episodes is because
it required so much CG
to put in the period stuff they shot the
show in LA but they had to use a lot of
CG to make it look like the 1940s the
good thing about Marvel Studios you know
as a film and TV studio is that Disney
which owns them also owns ILM one of the
best effects houses in the industry so
they can sell those services within the
company at a cheaper rate than they
could if they hired someone outside of
the company in case I forgot to mention
it x-men live-action TV series it's you
know it's in development but it's not
officially in the works yet because
Marvel owns the TV rights the x-men it's
kind of complicated so you might get
like a sony spiderman situation where
there's some sort of sharing I mean you
know Fox for instance 20th Century Fox
doing a Gotham TV show based on DC
characters if they can do that then Fox
and Marvel can probably find a way to do
an x-men live-action TV series on Fox
normally Monday nights or my Gotham
videos but because that's on break I
have extra room in my schedule so I'm
gonna be doing more Marvel and DC movie
videos if there's anything specific you
guys want me to do every week just leave
me suggestions in the comments I'm
probably gonna do a Deadpool video again
soon to my next video tonight will be
the Game of Thrones Q&A I'm giving away
a couple books so be sure to check that
video out don't forget there is an
agents of shield finale this week it is
two hours long you can click here to
catch up on that show right now if you
guys haven't been watching and you can
click here to catch up on the flash
before tomorrow night - it's like the
Knicks - last episode thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you